I was perusing the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum this morning
which you can find at david pakman.com
slash read it
that's re d di t now home to more than
3,100 of our viewers and listeners
they're really great political
discussion discussion of social issues
economic issues funny stuff from the
show really something for everyone
very little trolling now because of the
great job being done by the reddit
moderators which i think is a good thing
pat some people want trolling i
personally am not big on trolling little
trolling here and there is ok i think ok
alright
here's a few of the interesting
discussions from the reddit discussion
forum number one the gun industry is in
a slump due to donald trump fascinating
article from the federalists pointing
out that under obama gun sales were up
because of the constant fears irrational
fears of obama taking your guns
however under trump there are no such
fears and those gun sales are actually
down not great for the gun industry
interestingly enough very interesting
post also from the reddit discussion
forum what is the most constructive or
appropriate way to combat Islamic
terrorism this is a post actually from
one of our moderators it has generated
an interesting discussion it is I'm
finding it at least so far not to be an
ideological discussion but sort of a
practical discussion about what is the
best way to combat Islamic terrorism
also from the reddit discussion forum
someone saying David is right about
left-wing anti-semitism and this has
generated a big league discussion about
all sorts of anti-semitism both left and
right wing seventeen comments there
seventeen comments so far and building I
would add also from the read discussion
forum someone asking if there's any
chance of me interviewing Ben Shapiro
and I pointed out I actually have
invited Ben back on the program I have
interviewed him before someone posted
the link to that interview that Ben and
I have not yet been able to nail
anything down and lastly from reddit
this is funny someone posted they made
an image of the David Pakman show
reddit hierarchy and they created an
image where at the top in terms of what
is most prestigious
when it's posted to the David Pakman
show reddit this is in the view of one
one user by the way posting articles
from The Associated Press Reuters is
sort of considered like the top oh I
bought him cuz look at the brain there
it's very small I think as you get
towards the bottom a little more
pristine interesting more proceeded well
wow I completely misread it so the least
prestigious thing you can do according
to this user is post a pea or Reuters
articles next it's Ben Shapiro videos
followed by what is described as quote
cringe feminism and then the the most
prestigious or interesting or
groundbreaking types of posts to the
reddit according to this one user is
calling David a Jew [ __ ] on the live
stream I don't know that I agree now
that I realize that it's flipped I'm not
sure I agree with this assessment
well maybe the user didn't realize it
was flipped yeah you know maybe he got
it wrong but inception I like you're
getting into now what did someone else
think they thought when we thought about
their thinking and that's not a question
I'm prepared to answer today but what I
can tell you is you can join the reddit
at david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t we
crack ourselves up sometimes we do yeah